hey there Billy what's you up to I'm
learning about democracy this is where
the president lives right and after
Congress passes a bill the president
signs it into law I know that I know all
about democracy easy there Billy do you
know what happens after a bill becomes a
law it goes to nice people God
bureaucrats did you say bureaucrat Billy
well blow didn't think so anyhow there
are lots and lots of bureaucrats and
they make the regulations that bring
laws into the real world regulations
protect us from terrorists they even
punish people who do naughty things and
if we don't like the regulations we vote
out the bump ba bureaucrats the word is
bureaucrats and no you can't vote them
out because they've got jobs for life
well that doesn't sound like democracy
to me sure it does you see members of
Congress are busy people who have
important things to do we can't expect
them to explain how their bills will
work heck they don't even have time to
read the bills they pass so aren't you
happy there are so many bureaucrats
looking after you say yes well I'll tell
the DEA about daddy stash what's a stash
you